[Music]
thank you so much that was fantastic and
i'd love to welcome dr suzanne simard
live onto our stream from british
columbia welcome thank you thank you for
having me
and some of you have already been
putting messages into
our live stream we're already getting
some great questions we'll also have
kevin kelly one of our founders here at
long now come in for some live questions
um but i'll get us started you mentioned
uh how
some of these trees effectively have a
memory that's encoded
in their tree rings um and i think and
we got a chance to talk a little bit
about
some of the other ways that that worked
with some of the native cultures and
even the way that they harvested fish
can you talk a little bit about that
yeah so you know yeah so the memory of
trees is encoded in their
in their tree rings it's also encoded in
in their the genes in their
in their seeds um but you know in terms
of you know just annual growth rings of
a
current life of a tree um you know
there's so much information in those
rings
and thinking thinking of some of the
oldest trees in the world the
bristlecone pines are about 5000 years
old
there are trees along the west coast
redwoods and cedars that are
a thousand or two thousand years old so
that's a lot of history that's recorded
there
and one of the interesting things on the
west coast is that um
salmon salmon which migrate from the
ocean and spawn in the in the rivers
inland um carry with them a heavy
isotope of nitrogen
called n15 and n15 you can think of it
as
bio accumulating in these in the salmon
because they're
like top of their food chain and that
n15 that heavy isotope
can serve or we've used scientists have
used it as a tracer to see where that
salmon
nitrogen ends up and so when salmon are
spawning
um in the rivers we've people have found
that some of that n15 that some of that
salmon nitrogen
ends up in the trees so how does that
happen
well um when salmons spawn in the fall
there's bears that are preying on the
carcasses as well as wolves and
eagles and ravens and they they actually
carry it into the forest
in fact a single bear has been shown to
carry 175 fish in a single day
and they'll take it to their favorite
place
um sometimes under a big old mother tree
and with their cubs they'll eat
the flesh of this of the salmon usually
they actually they eat the brains and
the guts because that's where the most
energy is
and they'll leave the the fillets the
stuff that we like to eat
which decomposes and then the mica rises
actually
pick up that salmon nitrogen along with
the n15 that's embedded in those
proteins
and it is carried right into the tree
rings and becomes part of the
of the tissue of the tree rings and so
we can actually
shave off those tree rings and run them
through a mass spec and say okay there's
this much salmon nitrogen in this year
was absorbed by this tree
um and so then we can reconstruct
actually salmon populations over time
and i i would add one more thing to this
story
is that the that the first nations
people um knew this
for a long long time and they actually
helped cultivate or nourish the forest
by burying the guts of salmon that they
caught
at the base of trees or at the base of
salmon berries to
increase the productivity of the forest
they would also return the bones of the
salmon to the streams to increase the
mineral
content of the stream so it's better for
spawning of salmon
and also the last thing i would say is
they also had these ancient fishing
technologies
that really helped to increase the
salmon populations they would throw back
the big mothers for example
um so that the big you know that they
would
lay big eggs for bigger fish in the
future and they were always
um very conscious and aware of the
variability in the salmon populations
because they vary up and down over the
years they're on a four-year cycle
and so in the years where the salmon
populations were low they didn't take as
much
and they always threw back the big
mothers and then so doing kept the
salmon populations healthy
and that kept the forest healthy as well
and of course when colonization happened
that fishery those fishery technologies
were those ancient technologies were
were either outlawed or banned or or at
least
they weren't uh learned from anyway they
were ignored
and so then the the colonization of the
fishery actually has
decimated salmon populations and we can
see that in the tree rings as well
so it's that's interesting wow that's
such a miraculous story that we
have that kind of that much history to
understand both
not the just the plant world but the
animal world that surrounded it
um it's very cool and you know long now
has uh
bristlecone pines on our property in
eastern sierra and
learn we've been learning with the tree
wing lab and other other researchers
um like at unr about how much we do
learn out of those tree rings so it's
it's pretty amazing but i didn't know
the story about the salmon so it's yeah
that's really great
and we have a great question from uh
sean from our facebook feed um asking do
the micro razia serve only as
communication medium or
are they themselves originators of
messages too are they
are they adding information into that
stream or are they just helping the
trees alone
yeah no they're they're uh partners in
this whole
complex system as well and so like the
the fungi
um you know they have needs as well to
carry out their life cycle
and one of the needs that the tree
supplies is the is photosynthetic that's
the energy
um and the fungi when they're actually
colonizing a tree in order to
you know carry out their life cycle to
get the energy that they need
they signal back and forth between with
the tree the tree roots there's this
communication that goes on that's
biochemical it's constant
um and what the fungi do is they message
the tree
to soften their root roots basically um
so that they can enter into this
partnership and
the tree signals the fungi to
branch and create you know we call it
what we call apresarium where where they
will
contact the root cell and actually have
a a chemical and physical impact on the
root
that then the fungus can actually
colonize the root system
and then between fungi as well fungi
different species of fungi they
they compete they collaborate they
message each other as well
and bit with bacteria and the other
creatures in the soil there's a
there's a whole soil food web and they
all have these ways of
connecting and communicating with each
other and they enter into sort of this
food web where they have a food web of
feeding patterns and that feeding
pattern
is where you know larger
soil creatures will eat smaller and
smaller ones in that process of eating
down the food chain
they cycle nutrients because they
excrete out the excess nutrients
and that's what drives the the nitrogen
cycle for example in the phosphorus
cycle and all the sites these big
biogeochemical
cycles are actually based on or
dependent on these little tiny creatures
in the soil
right oh well that's amazing um and
after this question i'm gonna invite in
uh kevin kelly um but uh um you
mentioned
in the talk that you you've designed a
100-year experiment which i
love and there's so few of such things
in the world but i want to i'd love to
get a little bit of backstory on that
like
did were you funded as a 100-year
experiment or
you know do you have to kind of say it's
100-year experiment and then work on
funding of you know year over year or
yeah these are these are very difficult
longitudinal studies like this are very
difficult to
actually work in the world so i'd love
to hear the story behind it yeah i mean
working sorry working with long-lived
large creatures means you have to have
long-lived large
experiments and you can embed in those
sort of short-term experiments
to try to understand the mechanisms and
try to predict into the future of what
the long-term
trajectory might look like but you know
there's nothing like real data you can
have all the models in the world but you
need data to feed the models so that
they're accurate
and so these long-term large experiments
are crucial
um i i became you know quite good at it
when i was a young scientist because i
was
i was studying you know forest dynamics
and youngstands and we knew that we had
to have
large plots that we followed over long
periods of time and so there's a whole
infrastructure associated with doing
experiments like that
first you know finding the land to do it
on and then finding collaborators who
can work at that scale
and then of course as you mentioned
finding funders who will follow
your work for a long time and you know
honestly they don't
because um funding is usually on a
short scale right i think the largest
grant or the longest grant i've ever had
is five years and so yes it's a constant
process of
finding always finding money to to um
to keep the project going but you know
it's it's like
you know the more you do and the more
scientists get engaged with these
long-term projects that are
interdisciplinary
it does attract funding as well so i've
found in this project that it's actually
gotten
you know it was we were lucky to get the
money in the first place but
every year we've been successful at
getting funding and i think that
i think that that success will continue
because the project is a success
you know we're we're publishing a lot of
articles we're finding out new things
that
are directly relatable to climate change
you know i know that the government is
directly wanting our data in real time
so they can adjust their planting
policies for example
and so you know as as we've shown that
it's useful and
groundbreaking really um it i i feel
hopeful that we'll continue to get
funding
you know through the years but i do i
think it will always be the case that
it's going to be
piecemeal year after year we have to
keep chasing the money but
you know it's worth it yeah
yeah i mean it's it's interesting i mean
uh very obviously with things like
climate change we have to be able to pay
attention as a
civilization over decades if not
centuries
um so um it's amazing that you're
embarking on
such an experiment which i love to see
especially since we're short-term
thinkers
generally right where we at least you
know our economic
funding cycles are very short-term and
so it's it kind of goes against the
grain for long-term studies
um but it it you know we need to do it
we have to do it
right well i think finding the
mechanisms and governing systems that
can work in this case
um you know obviously there's things
like endowments that could kind of work
you know and you know some kind of term
but um endowing every long-term
experiment might be
a bit difficult but anyway we're going
to invite in kevin uh one of our
founders here at long now and the senior
maverick at wired welcome kevin
thank you what a great talk it opens up
all kinds of visions in my mind
one of them that i was surprised you
didn't mention that
may occur to other people was the vision
and avatar
of the of the fictional
world and how well that corresponds to
the picture you just painted um
and i have so many questions
about the mycelium themselves you you
you mentioned
that um they seem to treat transport
resources that you know with the new
seedling coming in and tapping into and
benefiting from
the old elders uh are the fungi actually
transmitting nutrients along the
mycelium for the benefit
of the other plants or is it their own
benefit and the plants are sort of are
they symbionic or what
what what that's a complicated picture
it's not just
bits that are communication but you're
saying they're actual
physical resources atomic material
moving along
is is that right yeah so you know
i know that um you know we i i often get
the question of who's in control here is
it the plants or the fungi
and the answer is both right they're
they're both
have agency in this and of course i'm a
forester and a tree person and so the
first thing
i did was i looked at the trees to see
you know if i adjust their
resource how replete they are in
resources
or how rich they are or if they're fully
enlighted or if they're in the shade
and i would change sort of like these
gradients between plants and i found
that
when i did that it changed how much of
these resources were
were moving and you're right it is it is
the resources it's the main things that
trees
and plants need which i and that's what
i looked at where water
you know nutrients nitrogen carbon those
are the big ones that they need and so
um and they are moving them around along
what we call
source sink gradients where you have a
source plant which is rich
to a sink plant which is poor in those
nutrients or those resources
the fungi themselves you know they have
needs too
they they um they need photosynthate or
they won't survive
because they don't have leaves they
don't have chlorophyll and so they get
that carbon that photosynthetic from the
trees and it's in their
best interest to be associated with
multiple plants and multiple trees
so that if one of them dies or a whole
species dies out of the forest
then they have other options they have
other trees that they're connected to
and so and so they are connectors right
and they do have
uh agency in how these resources are
moving around as well
and one of the ways to think about that
is um that
i mentioned that there are thousands and
thousands of species fungal species in
the world
in a single forest you can have a
hectare you can have about 100
fungal species and they have different
niches some of them are really
thick wide almost like
very carbon rich fungi others are very
fine and
you can barely you can't see them with a
naked eye they do different things some
of them are really
those thick ones are really good at
transporting water over long distances
um the really fine ones are good at you
know exploring into new places
and getting getting resources from
hidden places and then moving them
through the network um and so yeah so
so just their different roles their
different niches means that they will
have
they have a role to play and what gets
moved around and how much gets moved
around
it's not just the the sore sink gradient
among the plants and the trees but it's
also
the species composition of the fungi
themselves
so so the big picture you have is that
we have this forest and trees as social
beings and we know from animals which
are very social that their communication
can be used for cooperation but also for
competition
so is there any kind of evidence that
maybe trees
as you were saying can use the the
fungal mycelium to
transmit messages of like don't come
here stay away from me
um it's not the kind of cooperative
helping each other but actually
using it as a means of competition as
well
yeah yeah actually they can um so
um i know that some of these fungal
networks have been shown to transmit
even herbicides or allelochemicals a
little chemicals are like poisons
uh toxic chemicals that can actually you
know
uh poison another plant that it's
connected to
um and then and there's been a number of
papers written on that it's not from my
lab but other people
um and then but another thing that we
have looked at is
um is that you know we were working in
the arctic and
and one of my grad students julie deslip
was looking at bachelor nana which is
a shrub species that is actually
expanding across the arctic
as the as permafrost is melting and
bachelor nana it's a shrub it's been
slowly replacing or taking over
the tussock tundra and that's because
you know there's more nutrients
available as the permafrost melts
but also these bachelor nana are clonal
and they form mycorrhizal networks with
each other
and they transmit carbon from one
parent plant to a daughter plant to
another daughter plant and so on
and this has facilitated we think the
expansion of bachelor nana
across the arctic and that's not
necessarily a good thing because
it accelerates the warming and the
melting of the permafrost
on the other hand it also means we've
got more photosynthetic capacity
in the arctic but overall you know this
is a response that to
a fairly negative anthropogenic
climate change driven climate change
that that ultimately is
uh going to be difficult for us all to
deal with if if
people in the logging industry and
others
sure absorb your message about the
necessary social aspect of these forests
and
how it could benefit even them in the
long term are there new
technologies that would allow more
selective harvesting
or other ways to do this other than just
making it more expensive
are you aware of ways in which
we can necessarily do this without
necessarily making wood cost five times
as much
as it does right now which is very high
because of uh
shortages um so so is so are other kind
of solutions
to um working with this knowledge that
you have
you know i think that we've undervalued
our forest immensely
and we buy wood for like almost nothing
i know it seems like a lot because we're
not used to those prices
um but if we're really playing that the
true cost of clear-cutting our forests
would would be far far more expensive
and so
i think that um you know we we need to
adjust our economic expectations from
the forest and
actually value it for more than just two
by fours we need to value it for
the water the clean water that it
provides for the air it provides us i
mean how do you put a price on that
we need to put you know value it for the
carbon that can be stored
and already you know we're seeing
through carbon offsets and cap and trade
systems are
putting prices on carbon a move towards
that to valuing
ecosystems for the ability to store
carbon so it's a movement away from
these
very cheap products like two by fours or
toilet paper
that you know we've gotten used to
valuing force based on you know these
very simplistic
notions um and so yeah we can make that
change you know we need to
change the value of it just like you
know
we need to make conscious decisions we
need to make difficult decisions to get
off fossil fuels it's been
cheap for us to get that at fossil fuels
and we could kill ourselves easily by
just extracting it
extracting it but we need to make these
difficult decisions and say
no it's too expensive you know the
externality costs
of doing that are way too high you know
and um
and so sure it's possible of course it's
possible and
and i think that the way you know
to change the value what we need to do
is just slow
down right we're cutting the forest so
fast
for what right we're producing all these
products that we think that we need
um we could substitute products or we
can just
you know reuse products or be smarter
about art
you know the the products that that are
used for building
houses or you know we can just be a lot
more conservative less consumptive
and then when we do log the forest take
our time
right so that when we leave the forest
that it's regenerative
not not pushing it to the point of
collapse
which is what we're doing now we're
pushing these systems to the point of
collapse
and i don't think anybody wants that for
their children or their grandchildren or
you know to leave behind collapsed
ecosystems so yeah we've got to change
how we value
you know all these life support um
you know what we call goods and services
and ecology now
but all the life support system we need
to value it for what it is which is
allowing us to live on this planet okay
and my last question
uh just very briefly is taking off of
zander's point about long-term thinking
and long-term
projects are you aware of of other
100-year surveys in
your field and are there
best practices that are being done
in terms like say storing data that you
get this year to make sure that in 100
years someone can
get hold of it or other um
other methods or processes that would
encourage people to
also attempt a long-term 100-year
project like you have
you know there are some very large
projects in in the world
um that that need to be
protected and funded the face
experiments are one ex
one set of experience free error carbon
exchange experiments these are
huge and they're they're well-funded
where they're actually pumping co2 into
the atmosphere
in different ecosystems around the world
including forests and then looking at
the response to those
climatic changes that they're trying to
emulate um there's long-term
there's a long-term ecological research
experiments that
that have been funded by the usda forest
service
um and those experiments have been in
the ground for decades
um in canada you know we we have we have
joined into some long-term experiments
there's the long-term
site productivity experiments where
they're looking at how to prepare
soils over the long term but i'm not
actually aware of an experiment like
this one
you know where we've actually started it
with a shoestring
and then built it to be you know it's
basically
covers a 900 kilometer climate gradient
and uh and so it is unique and it's
unique in that we've collaborated with
so many different partners who are
interested we've collaborated with
you know with big major forest companies
we've
collaborated with little tiny community
forests we've collaborated with first
nations
um and and research forests and so we
have
lots of interest and we've built this
thing from the ground up
and i think that you know and we have
like you mentioned data
so you know we do store data in um the
microsoft
with microsoft and uh we have long-term
storage in the
ministry of forest it's it's registered
as a long-term experiment
and so but it it needs people to look
after it over time
and i know through my career which has
been a long career and i've have many
long-term experiments that data so
easily gets lost
even when you're doing the best that you
can you know suddenly that whole you
know first year data is gone who knew
where it went
so it's really important to invest in
data storage and curation and then the
continual publication of the data
it is it's a it's a big investment but
it's well worth
it because already you know in the
mother tree project even in the five
years that we've been doing this
we've found out things that you know can
change completely change how forest
practices work
for the better well i wish you great
success in the next 95 years
thank you
indeed i mean i think what's you know i
think a good experience thought
experiment always with these things is
imagine if we had this material and it
was already 95 years old
instead of just five years old like it
would be the most valuable data we had
on the planet to learn about climate
change
how it was going to affect us um if not
a thousand years of this data would just
be
amazing and i know um we also had a
speaker from
uh wayne clough when he was head of the
smithsonian i didn't realize this
the smithsonian is one of the longest uh
kind of uh
natural sites uh down in panama um
because of when the panama canal was
created but they've continued to do
biology down there for over a hundred
years which is very cool
um i wanted to ask uh we had a great
question from
uh our youtube thread um have you done
it
did you as a way of doing this um did
you
or anyone else do soil isolated
seedlings
as a as a control to learn about how
if they can't get to the mycelial
network how much worse or better their
lives are
in this forest yes for sure we've done
quite a few experiments like that and
um you know my graduate students over
the year years we've done it in various
forest types but we
they're very simple experiments you um
what we do is we create these chambers
um out of mesh of different sizes so the
mesh has got little tiny holes of
different
calipers different sizes that allow just
water to go through
or or maybe a fine mycelium or maybe
even a large mycelium
or a root to grow through or not nothing
can grow through
and we compare and we plant these bags
basically bags and fill them with soil
plant seedlings in them and they're
either connected to the old
trees if there's big enough pores in the
bags or they're disconnected if there's
no you know very tiny pores that only
water molecules
can grow through and then we compare how
those seedlings regenerate
and what we found is that when when
whenever a seedling can connect with an
old mother tree
that their survival goes up
significantly as does their growth rate
and their ability to to develop roots
and mycorrhizaes is all significantly
enhanced and in stress for us which i
emphasize so much
in the talk this is really really
important
you know if you're only getting 10
survival
without a network and then it goes up to
40 which is
roughly what we're seeing that's a big
deal right
that's a big deal for the forest so so
yeah
those experiments are not hard to do but
and they're but they're elegant
and they've provided us with huge
amounts of information
nice and i think i mean that to me the
two biggest pieces of news that i got
out of this one is that the way trees
communicate and especially interspecies
is amazing but this other
thing that you mentioned that that
actually we as humans can help
facilitate
moving uh forests to um to better
climates um
as climate change is happening to help
facilitate the regrowth
in um in clear-cut areas it's
potentially further north maybe than
they would have been
is a really important piece of
information that we can actually help
this situation
um and i wanted to ask do you know are
there any institutions or others that
are
like taking on this this task of having
of helping to recruit uh into the
changing environment that we're creating
yeah we're we're already in canada
actively doing that and i would guess is
happening in the us as well
so the geneticists have been working
long and hard on
you know for understanding you know the
genetic
uh or the genetic makeup of
seedlings and trees and and there are
local environments
and they call those provenances so so
they match a provenance to
um a planting area and in the last
10 years i would say in canada they've
been encouraging
um people to plant at least 10 percent
of the species mix
with genotypes that are from warmer
providences
so they migrate they're basically slowly
adding these migrants into the local
mixes of seedlings not
a hundred percent um and that's smart to
not do that it's got to be done
slowly um and and you know
moving genotypes like that because and
the reason that we're doing that
is because you know climate velocity is
about a thousand times
faster than the natural migration rates
and if the whole forest
dies because the you know because some
insect or fire because that was climate
driven wipes out the forest
um then we need to repopulate these and
we need to make sure they're resilient
and so that they've got the right
genotypes that can survive
and re-establish the forest um and we
need to make sure that we
bring these new migrants as i said in
the talk
into hospitable environments having old
trees left behind
and fires do leave old trees behind they
do
leave these legacies and and we need to
emulate that in our own harvesting
practices so that when we
migrate seedlings into new climates
where they
you know eventually will have a foothold
that they're
they're in an environment that will
receive them and protect them
and and allow them to get through those
very vulnerable early years
nice and i was encouraged to see in some
of the video in your talk that um that
young
uh i believe either undergraduates or
graduate students at least
are working in your lab and doing i know
we've talked to many
many of the kind of more extreme
explorers it's actually very difficult
for them to get the next generation to
go live out in these extreme
environments maybe your environments are
less extreme than some of these others
but how has how has it been to recruit
uh
young scientists into this field are
they enjoying it doing it
they absolutely love it i um i have a
crew of about 20 students out there
right now
um and many many students that apply and
i can't employ everybody who wants to
come
i have people from all over the world
saying can i come and volunteer
or you know even you know seniors saying
can i send you five bucks to support the
project and
um yeah so recruiting students is never
a problem and
it gives them you know they're part of
the solution then and
and then they you know talk to their
friends and they'll do
and they think of their own experiments
as well so
you know already a group of my students
are saying let's write a paper
on this one thing that i'm interested in
so you know we're training new
scientists for the future and we're
training advocates for the forest and
and once they get in those jobs they
don't want to leave them right because
they just absolutely
love it yeah it's really it's really
great it's really wonderful
well that's great and i just want to
close um so
i'd love to know if there's ways that um
that we can help you or follow your work
what are you doing next what's
how can how can our audience help and or
what's what's next for you
well you know i think the most important
thing is to
support the drive to save our old
forests
and so um that
and and i think that you know and to
tell your friends that this is an
important thing
it's important for everybody it's
important for us now
it's important for our kids our you know
for generations to come
this is we're at a crisis point and and
we've pushed our ecosystems
not just you know our oceans our land
our forest
and i said to the point of collapse and
we're continuing to do that
we need to pull back save these old
forests and so if you have an
opportunity
you know to um to help save the forest
so
like maybe investing in carbon offset so
that that we can
you know substitute making two by fours
with keeping carbon in the ground
so you can do those things you can push
your governments to make the right
decision instead of always go for the
expedient
short-term jobs thing or you know and
it's and
and to be honest the and i say the jobs
thing it's not that jobs are not
important it's just that
forestry has become so mechanized that
there are less and less jobs even as we
cut more and more trees
and this is i to me is the wrong
direction mechanization
and efficiency is maybe good for the
stock broker but it's not good for
the ecosystems and then of course you
can invest
directly in projects like this support
them because they always need
funding right the project you know i'd
love to
expand this project down into mexico
where where douglas fir is at at
southern limit but we can't work
just in canada because that's only where
our funding is from and we only have
limited funding so you could you know
invest in projects like this that span
much bigger latitudinal gradients and
you know you can donate to projects like
this if you want
right well and hopefully even projects
that span great
temporal gradients so thank you for
watching thank you for working on this
it's been amazing to talk with you
uh and i can't wait to follow your work
further thank you so much thank you so
much for having me
and i'd like to thank you our audience
and members and sponsors here at long
now this has been great and we look
forward to seeing you at the next talk
be well
you